one person and three dogs have lost
their lives in a fire on the east side
of town happened at a mobile home park
near sahara and sloan this afternoon now
homicide detectives have taken over the
investigation and are searching for a
person they believe is involved sasha
loftis joins us live tonight with the
latest
denise and brian we spoke with neighbors
in this area tonight and they say they
jumped in and tried to help but there
wasn't anything they could do now they
say they're just sad to see something
like this happen so close to home
when we got outside we saw the smoke
jeffrey green shares his shock after a
home in his neighborhood went up in
flames wednesday there were people
coming up from all over the place to see
what they could help with one person who
police say is most likely a woman was
found dead inside along with three dogs
smoke from the blaze seen billowing into
the sky in this drone video we are still
trying to determine what led up to the
fire metro homicide detectives are now
investigating and say hours before this
fire started officers responded to an
argument over property at the same
location
the people involved are believed to be
the person who died and a man police are
still searching for as they work with
firefighters to comb through any
evidence it's very
hard to process this crime scene to the
fact that clark county fire
tried used a lot of water and resources
to put out the fire as for jeffrey he
says he and others in the area are upset
to see this kind of thing right in their
backyard kind of sad that it's in our
neighborhood but these things do happen
and heartbroken for the family affected
by such a sudden tragedy definitely not
anything i would wish on anybody
detectives say this investigation is
still in its preliminary stages you can
see the scene behind me is still very
much active as they continue
investigating if you have any
information as to where the man involved
in that initial argument
maybe you are asked to call crime
stoppers reporting live tonight sasha
loftis live local now